- Today we have a very special event.
I think this is probably the first time
in the history of the Yale Council
of Southeast Asian
Studies Brown Bag Series
that we have undergraduate speakers.
In fact that we rarely have
graduate students speakers,
but I was so inspired when
I heard about the work
that is going on by these students
at the Fulbright University of Vietnam,
in collaboration with
colleagues in Myanmar,
and other organizations
across Southeast Asia,
that it really struck a chord with me
about the importance of
Inter-Asian students solidarity,
especially in these times.
It's something we often
talk about as scholars
about the importance of
Inter-Asian research, right?
But in a moment of
decolonizing the academy,
rethinking Southeast Asian Studies.
To see students from Vietnam
who are taking an interest in Myanmar
to me is a signal of
the important directions
of that scholarship and activism
and thinking and work needs
to be going in the future.
So I was really excited
to be able to find a slot
in our Brown Bag to afford the possibility
for today's event.
The event will be inspired by a Zine,
on life and Post-Coup Myanmar.
That the Phuong Anh and Tam
Nguyen, have been working on
with other collaborators
at Fulbright University
and with a collaborator in Myanmar.
And they'll be talking about that today,
but let me just say a few
words about who they are.
So Phuong Anh Nguyen
is a history sophomore
at Fulbright University in Vietnam
whose current interest is in
human rights in Southeast Asia.
Tam Nguyen is a poet, art writer,
apprentice curator based
in Ho Chi Minh City,
his practice merges, creative
writing, critical theories
and art history to investigate Vietnamese
and Southeast Asian modern
and contemporary cultural spectacles
in light of neoliberalism
and globalization.
They're gonna talk for about 20 minutes
about their Zine project.
Then after that, we'll also
be joined by Laure Siegel,
who is a Journalist and
Founder of Visual Rebellion,
a grassroots movement of
creators for creators,
and they stayed on their website,
that they believe that
photography, film, and art
have the power to create
change for the better.
They are dedicated to
helping Burmese creatives
by providing a platform for their work
in opposition to the military junta.
Extremely timely and important work.
So I'm really excited to have
Laure joining us here as well.
If internet conditions allow,
we will also have a guest
who will be going by
the name of Marla Lamay,
hopefully joining when the
internet allows from Myanmar
and joining in on the conversation.
So the structure of our event
will basically be for the
first 20 minutes or so
we'll hear about the Zine.
Then we'll hear a little
bit about Visual Rebellion
and then we'll quickly turn
it after about half an hour,
a total to open Q and A discussion.
And we really hope that will
be a dynamic conversation
that brings in all kinds of
voices during the conversation.
So without further ado,
let me turn it over to
Phuong Anh Nguyen and Tam.
- Hello everyone?
- Thank you for the
amazing introduction you.
(speaking in a foreign language)
- Yeah, let me handle the introduction.
So hello everyone.
I'm Tam Nguyen, and thank
you for the very kind
and warm introduction from Eric's
and the lunch backers in general,
and thank everyone for taking your time
and be here with us today.
So let's get straight to the point
Anh Nguyen has been working
for a consecutive period
of Faltman since September.
I think it September, October of 2021,
as soon as we know and
understand a little bit more
about what's happening in Myanmar
after to the coup that took over
the government in February,
2021, and we felt lighter.
There's an urgent need
for us to do something
that make this specific issue visible
to the international community.
So, yeah.
Let me just quickly share
my screen right now.
Okay, Phuong Anh you can start
talking about the project.
- So thank you Tam.
So our project is an independent project,
started out as a very personal
project to both me and Tam
because we feel very strongly about
what is happening in Myanmar
and through our personal
encounters with the people
who work on Myanmar and who is
currently living in Myanmar,
we decided to start this project
and our project is a nonprofit,
independent and overarching project
that highlights the extreme
violence in Myanmar,
which is not been fully covered
by in international media.
Can you move to that next slide please.
So for today, after the introduction,
we will talk about why
we started the Zine,
why it is a Zine and what are the contents
that we will walk you through
the content in the Zine.
And we will share more about the insight
into like the process of making the Zine,
conducting the interviews
and even the translation,
as well as the designing
process of the Zine.
After that, we will
have a small discussion,
which I hope to be.
I really look forward
to have with the youth
from Southeast Asia,
like Visual Rebellions
and students from Southeast
Asia movement from Yale.
And lastly, we will talk,
we'll spend five minutes
to send out appreciation
to the people who have helped us
with the production of the Zine,
as well as who have helped us
to promote the Zine as well.
Thank you.
So for, as I shared a bit before,
the reason why we started this project
is because we felt intrigued
by the recent youth resistant
campaigns in Myanmar
since the February coup.
And we are just a group of
undergraduates and artists
with support from the students
from Yangon University.
And we decided to initiate
a multimedia project
that centers around a hybrid artistic,
non scholarly Zine publication.
This project is meant to direct attention
to the current political
turmoil, of course,
Myanmar with the Southeast
Asia at this targeted audience.
And that's it, we intend
to collect stories
and perspective from people of Myanmar
who are living on this
escalating violence,
as well as we want to
include international
and regional stances in responses
to the humanitarian crisis as well.
If we have access to the resources
and all of these will be communicated
through a multimedia project
consisting of a series
of events and activities
centered around Zine publication.
So we have received a lot of support
from our organizations from Fulbright
and as well as from students
from University of Yangon
and we believe that in the possibility
and long term impact of this project
as to surface and highlight
the voices of the people
living in post school Myanmar.
So from Fulbright, we have
Fulbright Historical Society,
an undergraduate community
started in Fulbright
aiming to promote the history
discipline and scholarship.
Fulbright Historical Society
also provides history enthusiasm
with sufficient supports
to nurture their interests
and the ability to thrive
in both in academic
and professional setting.
And we have Fulbright Art Lab,
a student run organization
based in Fulbright University,
Vietnam founded in 2018.
And Art Lab has coordinated
numerous events and programs
such as film screening, panel discussions,
exhibitions, aiming to create a connection
between art labors and
communities in Vietnam.
And we receive a lot of support
from Interim University
Council, University of Yangon.
And IUC-UY is recognized
as the legal administrator
of University of Yangon by
National Unity Government.
And they're working accordingly
with the NUG Ministry of
Education and also independently.
IUC-UY has many working processes
and has different branches.
One of them is International
Cooperation Team
in which they try to connect
with oversee universities
to support their democratic movements,
to fundraise and to raise awareness
about not accepting non-city
and military supporters.
And the moment that I
talked with my friends
from Yangon University about the project,
she immediately communicated back
with the university council
which includes faculty staffs
and also students from the university.
And we received full support from IUC-UY.
So a lot of appreciation to IUC-UY
for helping us with the Zine.
So all of the intellectual properties
produced in the Zine publication,
as well as in our project,
we'll be used to raise fund
for the IDPs in Myanmar.
And we have listed all donations
sent to my PayPal account
will be distributed equally
to four organizations
listed below for the Chin State.
It will be the Tantlang
Placement Affair Committees,
for Kachin, is the Kachin Relief Fund.
Karen, is the Dawkalu Network.
And for Karenni is the Karenni Guys,
and we are waiting for an
official bilingual issue
from UIUC-UY to confirm my reliability
in distributing the fund
sent via my PayPal account
to these organizations.
And here is our.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- So this is here is the
interface of our web website
and through this website,
and you can see there's
like a tiny QR code
on the right side of it.
You'll be able to access our website,
which also houses our Zine publications.
And we'll talk about the Zine
publication in two minutes.
So let's talk a little bit
about our own, you know,
like personal encounters
with our very first knowledge of Myanmar
and what's happening in the country.
In 2021, I participated in
an art writing symposium
that contains a lot of like
curators and art labors
and artists across Southeast Asia.
And we got together in
this specific program
called Term and Condition
or reading and publishing
in Southeast Asia
organized by a certified
now and (indistinct)
under the organization (indistinct).
So in this very specific
program, we talk a lot about,
you know, like the state
of culture production
in contemporary.
So Asian as well, a lot of the history
that underline this very
process of development.
And as I had a talk with a specific,
this very specific like Burmese scholar
who just got back from
getting her degree in the US,
she got back right back to Myanmar
and started working there as a teacher
and also in parallel with
raising fund for the resistance,
which is something very powerful.
I had not known before,
because a lot of the people
who join the revolution are
actually people at my age,
and I can just not faith
them, how that very audacity
and a belief in something
that is judicious
for by a collective democracy
would be that powerful
to mobilize such a
massive number of people.
And especially, again,
those are people at my age,
the youngsters are putting
themselves out there
and facing direct and seeing the brutality
committed on daily basis.
So I decide that's the moment for me
to get to know a lot more about
what's happening in Myanmar.
And most of my information
comes from Instagram
because we are like gen z people, right?
So we do a lot of Instagrams,
and it's very interesting to
see that a lot of these reports
from independent journalists
often come from Instagram
accounts that are often private
so that you can see the
contents with the censorship.
And those become my main
sources of information
to keep me updated about situation
and like which regions of Myanmar
is turning into a war zone
and stuff like that.
And in light of the
Ukraine Russia conflict
that is happening recently,
you know, the news of the Myanmar,
and especially there's
one specific article
about us and being in prison
or being charged with
three years in prisons,
it just made it to the news
for around like three
days before sliding back
into the virtual archive of the internet,
which is something that I
cannot really understand
because like the level
of brutarian balance
is just beyond our understanding,
especially in the contact
with 21st century.
So we decided to...
This is the moment when we
bring all of this to the right.
So Phuong Anh, if you
can talk a little bit
about your present
experience with this as well.
- And so in Fall of 2021,
I participated in a one credit
course by Cornell University,
also the Southeast Asia
program from Cornell.
And the course was called Scholar Activism
and the Spring Revolution in Myanmar.
And in that course,
I and a friend from University of Yangon
was like the only
undergraduate students there.
And after the course, I
felt like deeply inspired.
And then I like for a country,
like right in Southeast Asia
and like only two and a half hour slide
from my hometown people are being killed,
being abducted and burnt alive.
And I couldn't comprehend what the,
like I feel very deeply for
what is happening there,
but I couldn't comprehend like
how such thing could happen
for, in a place that's so near to me.
And right after the course,
I went Fulbright Historical Society's hub,
I organized a webinar
on humanitarian crisis
in Southeast in Myanmar.
And after the webinar,
I felt like I need to do something more,
not just stopping at like a small webinar.
So I asked them about,
do you wanna do a project with me?
And we both feel very strongly
about what's happening in Myanmar.
So we got together
and after I communicated that our project,
which started as like two
students from Vietnam,
doing an independent project
with my friend from Yangon University.
And she asked if we wanted to
collaborate, and here we are,
we have this project
after like four months
of working very closely together
with the Yangon students.
- So in the next part of the presentation,
we took a little more deeply
about like the process of us,
like coordinating with people
that is very far away from us
based on nearly like internet connections,
which is another very interesting aspect
of the collaborative kind of
effort within this project.
So you see on the screen right now
is the outline of our manuscript
of what we're having right now in the Zine
and keep in mind a lot of
this content are in the Zine,
but some other future informations
and concept will be posted on our website.
So please take tuned for that
beforE now, we'll talk a
little bit about the Zine
and for the interest of time,
we will just brief through several section
that we think is what's
best highlight the,
what was interesting
about the Zine itself.
So why Zine?
Why?
So I don't think people
would be very familiar
with but this very specific
type of publication,
but it's a person who worked in the arts
for quite a while right now,
Zine is something that we as art labor
has been taking into consideration
when we approach a topic
that has a relatively
different kind of approach
compared to other traditional publication.
And now we are taking
into account the urgency
of the series of events
that's happening in Myanmar.
And we also wanted to bring
our own narrative into this
and to make it as flexible
and at the same time
as creative and as critical as we can,
so that we are not bound to
any kind of like standards
or limitation whatsoever.
So we decided to up the
Zine, which is a free flow
and kind of like non regulated
kind of form of publication.
And then you see what Zine
looks like in the next part.
So the first thing in our
Zine is I think Phuong Anh,
you can talk about this
very specific interview
and the process of our friend Costa
has gone through in order to,
and also the story behind it.
- So I work closely with Costa
a student from Yangon University,
and to produce the interview with the IDPs
and the interview with the
students from the CDM students,
and for the interview with the IDPs,
we have one is the story a
small anecdote of a volunteer
in an IDP camp in Myanmar.
And she shared about her experience,
her Christmas celebration
experience at the IDP camp,
which was majority Christian.
And also in that day, as we
were updated on Instagram
about the burning of 35 people
while they are being on their
way to fleeing to an IDP camp.
They were caught by the Tatmadaw soldiers,
and they were burned alive on the truck
after hearing that news.
And after we just had a
meeting the day before,
so that when she came to
the Christmas celebration,
she can collect the, Costa
can collect the story
for our Zine publication.
And right after that, the day after,
we received a new of 35
people being burnt alive,
and we decided to incorporate it
into the story about
Christmas celebration.
And yeah, we work very closely.
Like we talk almost like every day
to get updated with each other,
to share the experience
living in Post-Coup Myanmar
and living in the states
where ethnic conflicts happen
alongside with the struggle for democracy.
Yeah, so to produce the interviews
beside from like working
very closely with each other,
talking almost every day,
we also have the ethical
conduct consultation
with our psychology professor
from University Vietnam,
Dr. Jill Skultip.
And because this is a non
scholarly publication,
we consult with Dr. Jill
for guidelines in ethical in interviews
to protect our interviewees
and interviewers
solely because we are so afraid
of like hurting them any more
from what they are experience already
have already been experiencing
by the interviews that we want to do.
So the interviews are not IRB approved,
or it is not scholarly.
They are just consulted and conducted
following the ethical conduct
guidelines for research.
But they are not research material.
- So alongside with the interview
with the IDB frontier
that we just presented,
we also have several other interviews,
different person in
different walks of life
processing different professions
and how they all came together
into a very kind of unify kind like state
of being in the context
of Post-Coup Myanmar.
And here, like I mentioned
in the beginning,
I have interview with
a Burmese arts scholar,
who just finished her degree in the State,
and just literally just
came back to Myanmar
and started working like a part-time job
alongside with like,
doing everything that
she can to raise fund
and raise awareness about
what's happening Myanmar.
So here in the interview by Diana Zaw Win
I tried to go very deeply
into her academic interests,
especially given that her background
are in Burmese culture and Burmese history
in association with, you
know, like visual theories
and art history in general.
So a lot of these interesting perspective
would be covered by Diana alongside
with her contemporary
take on the coup attack
as well as the revolution,
the Spring Revolution of 2021.
And alongside with that,
once I have other interviews
with an undergraduate student
at the University of Yangon
as well as a high school student,
which you can also fight in the Zine.
And I think another
interview with a PDF soldier
where they will, where he would talk about
what's the real life
looks like for a soldier
who is gonna stationing in the jungle
and how, and also this,
as you can see on the
screen those are the images
of the resistance soldier are training,
where they're training
and how they're training.
And you can find all these details
in that specific interview as well.
So the Zine is kind of a hard part
of a lot of different things
that we think that would best portray
life in Post-Coup Myanmar.
So will also include a poems written
in the form of arbitrary
dedicated to a foreign soldier.
And we have a Burmese version of it,
as well as a English translated version,
which was translated by Onio,
who unfortunately could not be here today.
But also please have a look at that
if you're interested as well.
And we also have commentaries
because I myself as an art student.
So I'm always interested
in how the relationship
between art and the social construction,
especially at the time
where revolutionary spirit
are very heated in Myanmar
and the brutality of the tap
is kids present in everyday
it's very essential to
see how art has become
one of the essential instrument
to look at the entire spectacle of Myanmar
as well as a means of the system.
So you can find some of that
in my essay were discussed
to specific artists that
I think best represent
the idea about art is a site of a system.
And this is a very interesting article
provided by Phuong Anh.
So I think we can talk about as well.
And then this is especially
connect with the,
I think what Eric has called
by certain Asian youth solidarity.
So Phuong Anh can you talk a
little bit about your article.
- Thank you, and so I, because
well, most of the content
in arts in publication are quite heavy
in terms of like emotions and content.
So I decided to write
something still serious,
but it has more of a humorous
and comedy kinda of vibe to it.
And I wrote about meme-ology
of the Spring Revolution
and how the youth use their...
That the young people is their
nature, their common language
of talking with international communities,
international youth using memes
to use those into doing revolution,
as well as raising awareness
about what is happening in their country.
And also, I think you'd,
to people can go to our website
and read our Zine
to know more about the commentaries,
but I think it is time for
us to give the spotlight
to the Visual Rebellion teams.
So they can share a bit more
about their project as well
as their organization.
- Thank you.
Very interesting.
And we do some similar
very exciting interesting.
So I will introduce myself.
I'm Laure Siegel, I'm
a French Correspondent
in Beijing, Bangkok for eight years.
And I was also, I had the
chance to be a media teacher
in Yangon before the coup in 2019.
So I kept in touch with my
students and after the coup
a few days after some
of them reached to me
because they simply did the
work they have been trained for.
So they went in the
streets in every hometown.
They were so, as you know,
COVID stopped most of studies
and most students had to
go back to their hometown.
So when the coup happens,
they were in their hometown
because study was
interrupted already before.
And so when it happened,
they spontaneously went
out to take picture to film
because they wanted to document this.
And because some of them
were already working
for the local media.
So we have mostly people
in the ethnic states.
So Rakhine and Shan and
Karenni, and Maguey, Shwedaung,
and one or two person in Yangon.
Saw the ideas that we would cover,
places that were not the main areas
and where the information
was very difficult to get.
So the best way is to have
local train young journalist
who have connection, who the territory,
who know the local language.
So it started, I will try to be quick.
It started, we called it
the Myanmar Photo Project Collective,
can I share screen maybe
so I can show you how it's, yeah.
The Myanmar Projects, streets of protest.
So I told them we work with
10 people at the beginning
in all these areas.
So every day they would go out
and they would send picture information
and together we would the caption.
So we have all dates, all
context, all location.
And we translated every slogan
to right at the beginning.
So the beginning of the project,
so this is standard can
stay the first days.
And we did, I will do it quick for you,
but this is Yangon, and we did 15 episodes
of archive picture from street
protest from everywhere,
and we stopped.
I will show you the last
episode, we stopped early May,
end of March because as
you might know, March 27,
first day in Myanmar, it
was extremely violent,
the oppression and at this
point it was just too dangerous
was to go in the streets
and also in most places,
the big gathering stops.
So the last episode was a silence strike,
actually, with just as
we talk about creativity,
people found ways to express
things in a different way
with no people to avoid
danger of arrest or worst.
So this was against a demonstration
against sexual harassment for
women who arrested in jail.
And because there was
big scandal in April.
And then we had the last
picture from Mandalay,
and it stopped with the Geria strike in.
So this was already
oppression in Mandalay.
And then early May,
we got the last picture
from our journalist in Tamwe
where it just went very violent.
So it went for the flash strike.
So 15 people went away and
even then even on this day,
people got arrested.
So it got very dangerous.
So we switch to first,
we collaborate with the NGO
human rights in the picture
we based in the Netherlands
and for decades,
they are helping filmmakers in countries
where you have a huge political shock
where people cannot walk anymore.
And then to help them save their footage,
to help them do something with it edit
and give an audience to the movies.
So we did the photo part and we created,
sorry, visual rebellion you know.
So this is collaboration
between our collective
of photo journalists
and this organization
who help film making.
So the Major Reuben who is the founder.
She helps put on this filmmaker
that we will keep his name
anonymous to make his documentary
because for months he films
in Yangon in Shan state,
in Karen state and then
finally came to Thailand
and now he's safe in another country,
but we combine him all the way
so he can finish his movie.
And so this is the website.
And so the second thing
we decide to switch
is that because we cannot
send people in the streets
to cover street protest anymore,
because it's so unsafe,
we switch to research.
So as you know, most
international organization
cannot send their people inside Myanmar
to get information on the ground.
The think tank cannot work.
Most of the foreign staff
have been pulled out,
and then you had all this
budget opportunities.
This need to know what was happening.
And we said, we can fulfill this need
because we have trained
local media workers
across the country.
And we started doing research.
So collaborating with Researcher Republic,
which is a think tank that
was created 10 years ago
in Myanmar and they provide
confidential reports.
And then we publish with them
a report about cyber security
in Post-Coup Myanmar.
And then it's long report.
You can see I will not open
them, it's 50 page each,
but the idea was to
teach young journalists
to work with young researcher,
and then to get a comprehensive
idea of the situation
that were both compelling in
a telling a journalistic way,
but also with the academic context.
So this one was about all
the economic difficulties
in the country and how people are coping,
how people are resisting.
Our last one publish is about the world
that is being built at the moment,
between China and Myanmar.
And so we choose topics
where we have people,
but that are out of international
interest, of course,
so the next one will be about the pipeline
and what's something along the pipeline
from our time to come in.
And then we have one on the
situation of women in IDP camps
millions of people, one
of displaced by the war
and was a situation for them.
And we also do, but this, all
of this is we provide content,
but it's a school, it's to
continue the pedagogical,
the training that was interrupted
because of COVID of the coup,
because this is experience
they would've learned by themselves,
but now it's not possible.
So we continue this journalism
school we do by learning.
So they get a lot of time
to three, four months
to work on a long future.
And at the same time,
we are doing a lot of work on the side.
So we have English lesson
online every evening
to be most opportunities to learn more.
And for the people, what
to flee to Thailand,
we help them logistically
we organize workshop here.
And so the idea is to
provide all opportunities
they should have to continue
and to have a future as journalists,
as academics at the same time
that we provide very
localized verified content.
And what we want to do is
actually to have Thai journalists
and Burmese journalists working together,
because most of Burmese people,
when they can flee to Thailand.
So you have lost of the media now here,
and we're still working
with the sources in Myanmar,
but we need support.
A lot of them are in (indistinct) paper.
So we also help with
this getting scholarship,
getting them to university,
getting some paper.
And this is why I have
also invited in the talk,
my two colleagues.
So we have Keyo who's a Thai journalist
who was covering before for
Thai Media Myanmar issues.
And then we have Nicole who
is basically the profounder
of the collective because
he contacted me first.
And is the journalist from Yangon,
and is the author of this report.
So we research cyber
security for four months
and we published this
and he is also the author of short movie.
So if you allow me,
I would like to show
you a short documentary
that was done by him on this,
because we talk on signal
and all his audio.
I get all his stories by audio now.
So this is one, this is his
experience from the ground.
So we do photo research video
why empowering people in
the professional life.
So this is one movie and
we have six like this,
and then I will pass to Keyo.
(protestors ranting)
- [Keyo] Sorry for my late reply
As you know, it was
not easy to communicate
because this situation is not good.
It was two weeks ago
and now so many people got hurt by a bomb.
Every night two to three
bomb explode in the city.
I mean I'm okay at least I was alive.
I mean, I'm okay.
I don't know how long we
will have this situation.
Every day, I am thinking about my future.
How long it will take?
And how long we have to wait
to end this?
Sometimes I was lose my ambition.
Sometimes I was depressed.
Everyday it becomes
harder and harder to live,
to eat, to sleep.
I have no idea how do
I live in this country.
Some days I wish I just go
to live on the moon alone.
But I was trying to stay
strong, if I am depressed
and just think about I'm okay.
I must stay alive.
At least I must not die.
I must not get hurt.
I am trying to motivate my mind with that.
- Okay, sorry, stop sharing my screen.
And so it was not very
organized as a presentation,
but you can ask us anything
and just to finish why we have our ideas
to have Thailand and Burmese
young journalists work together
because obviously they face
some of the same issues
in the generation and it's about politics,
but it's also about the Mekong River.
It's so many things
that people are sharing
and have to learn about each other
and the countries and the
similarities in the methods
of the leaders and the colonies
and there is so much people
can learn from each other.
So we also organize workshop
where people can share the,
Thai and Burmese journalists
can share the experience
of covering protest of relationship
with state authorities of prison life
of environmental struggle
and how trying to stay safe
and how trying to do
work that will be seen
because we have also this
problem that Southeast Asia
has gone a bit in a whole of interest.
And there was some
interest for some months
in the beginning, but then
since the war in Ukraine,
it's very difficult to get
people interested in Myanmar.
And this is also why we, which
way to expand our articles.
We can explore our website.
We have articles twice a month
about what we think is the main event.
And actually five days after
the invasion of Ukraine,
Kenyan people went protesting
from the Russian embassy
in Bangkok, and some
Thai people were there
and some Burmese people were there.
So it was pretty incredible to see this,
even not original solidarity
and people could see the
same enemy in the eyes
and make connection with business
and military power and interest them.
So we write about this too.
How the situation in
Myanmar is not isolated
and that it says a lot to
what's happening in the world.
And of course, Myanmar was
such a hope for a lot of us.
And if Myanmar fall,
you have a feeling that it's a
bad trend for Southeast Asia,
because they were showing
something else, very imperfect,
but it was something else.
There was something else.
And so we tried to explain
that supporting Myanmar
is supporting an idea in
Asia, but also beyond that.
So you can ask any question
you want to my colleagues
who also on the ground.
And of course, to Miko,
we did a incredible work
half of the work collective.
And so thank you and
sorry for the time, yeah.
- Thank you, Laure.
So at this point, we will
have an open discussion.
Thank you so much for both
of these presentations.
I invite people to raise their
hand using the chat feature
or the reaction feature on Zoom.
And when the hand goes up,
I'll invite you to ask the question
and I'll keep track of a queue.
Maybe I'll start off with a
question for Phuong Anh and Tam
and maybe it's a mildly
sensitive question.
And so you don't have
to answer it completely
if you don't want to,
but your students at Fulbright University
and you're working on a topic
that raises certain questions
about what's happening in Myanmar,
I'm curious how you feel
about the sensitivity
of raising these topics
within Vietnam itself.
Obviously you're not talking
about the politics of Vietnam
in a particular way,
but you are talking about
another country a Zine right?
And Vietnam itself has
certain obligations to a Zine,
but a Zine has proven itself
to be very unable to stand
up and make any claims.
And so how do you navigate that situation
as young Vietnamese students
who are seeing this tragedy,
but also being mindful
of your own position?
- So I think I would
like to take the question
and if Phuong Anh have anything to add on,
feel free to chime in,
but you're right, Eric,
that exactly the first thing
that we have to think about
when even before we start to
have any tangible outcomes
of the project, because
we are fully aware that.
So apart from the thing
that you said about Vietnam
being attached to like
the non intervention,
kind of like mandate between
South Asian countries
at the same time, when
we talked about events
and information that concerns keywords
such as rebellion, revolution,
and to resist against a certain
sort of unite government.
So those are some of the things
that we will have to communicate
very, very carefully,
even though that our main goal
is to still bring out the rawest
and the most kind of a
genuine kind of a perspective
within the Zine.
So in the beginning we intended
to make it a physical kind of publication.
So we would have the hard
copies for people to get
and hold in their hands and get them like,
if they're interested in.
But a lot of that has
been probably left aside
because of the communications,
when it comes to print publications,
and especially under
the context of Vietnam,
those are one of the things
that are considered to be taboo
and taken into considerations
of the content itself.
So eventually, so we also
intended to have like,
a Vietnamese version,
an international version
where everything would be in English.
So we also went through a lot
of like stages of consulting
with different people who
have experienced working
in independent publication.
We call ourselves independent publication.
And even though we are
receiving help from organization
and you know, like affiliated organization
that we presented in the beginning,
but we're still a student
led kind of a project
and we're providing our own narrative
based on the materials
that we've collected.
So a lot of that would not guarantee us
like a certain neutrality
or a certain discourse
where we would not be touched
by forces that like unwanted forces.
So eventually we decided to
make the Zine talent English,
first of all, to like
to make the narrative
a little more audible among
the international community
and not limited within
the Vietnamese community.
And we are participated
in this project as people.
So we don't really identify
with our own national,
you know, like attribution,
but rather a group of people
who are, who want to pay more attention
into the issue that's
happening in Myanmar.
So that is like the very premise
that we really want to make clear
so that when readers approach our project,
they also have a much clearer
idea on where we started
and where we are now.
So that's my respond,
I hope that answered your question though.
- [Erik] No, thank you.
That was a wonderful answer.
Paul Sarno has a question.
- Forgive me for some basic question but,
how often is the Zine published?
How many issues have you brought out?
And is it, I assume it's in paper
or give me the details please.
- So I can take this question.
So this is our first publication.
We have been working on this publication
since the end of October.
And, but for future plans,
we don't promise any new publication
or any established publication,
but we do have articles,
blog posts, and events,
which we would very
gladly be collaborating
with Southeast Asia dues,
as well as seem from Yale
to have like cross promotion,
as well as like have our articles,
co-write or like have
collaborations on writing articles
and conducting interviews
or researches if possible,
the focus of our collaborations.
We really want to collaborate
with more youth organizations
and youth led movements
from Southeast Asia
and from the international community
to rise awareness about
the crisis in Myanmar,
the humanitarian crisis in Myanmar.
We want to focus on young
independent youth led
and people led prodigal proceed projects
because we are also independent.
We are also young and often
these groups, the people,
the youth are often the
marginalized voices.
And we want to, like, if
we go and we rise together,
we want to like service their own work,
as well as servicing their voices,
their narratives about what is
actually happening in Myanmar
for now we only know that
about Visual Rebellions,
not know, but like have
connection with Visual Rebellions
in Southeast Asia Movement at Yale.
But there are many other organizations,
as well as people who are
are out there for example,
there was a youth led podcast
about Myanmar on Instagram,
and I really want to collaborate
with that led podcast,
but I haven't reached out to them yet.
- Okay, thank you.
- Thank you, Eric.
White, do you have a question?
- Yeah, I have I guess a similar question
for both of the participants
one it's basically,
I'm kind of, I'm just
curious to know more about
your interactions with
your respective peers
and colleagues and what
their responses have been.
So for Tam and Phuong Anh
and other students at the university,
other students in Vietnam,
I don't even know if
there's other students
in association groups in Southeast Asia
and for Laure I'm just
wondering about more established
kind of, you know, as a
photo journalist collective,
what about more established
photo journal, you know,
or journalistic media
groups and organizations,
or even advocacy groups, NGOs, whatnot.
So, yeah.
- So I think for our project,
from our place through frontline,
like I said, in the beginning,
it's a very, it's an extremely independent
kind of project that involves.
So like two of us, like me and Phuong Anh,
we are the main editors of the Zine.
So we're in charge of
collecting the materials
in very close and discreet
collaboration with friends
from the Interim University
Council University of Yangon,
so a lot of these people
help like venture out there
into the battle fields,
as well into the IDP
can to actually collect
intervene all of those
would be entirely in Burmese
or like local dialectics
that would need like another
person from the same team
to actually translate them
so that we can like acquire the
material entirely in English
or like language barrier is
something that we also consider
whether its project, but we're
fortunate to have friends
that are very passionate
about the project itself.
And so capable of coordinating with us
during the editorial process.
So everything happened in a very,
you know, like case by
case kind of like basis
and sometime internet
connection would not allow,
you know, like continuing
kind of conversation to go on.
So sometime we'll have to take breaks
between within the process.
So eventually a lot of the materials
that we were not able
to get would be let out
and perhaps in the future,
they may reappear on the category
block post on our website.
But again, everything in
our project is very organic.
I think that's the word,
the fact that we, you know,
each other, both their
friends and his colleague
and we just try to showcase EDN
what we have on in our hands.
And I often jump to Phuong
Anh is that this Zine
has an expiry date due to
the urgency of the matter
that it want to communicate.
So with the opportunity from
Yale at the Brown Bag Serie
as well, so I future
collaborations with Zine,
we want to make this scene appearance
as prominent as possible
so that more people would get to read it.
So that's our main goals for
perhaps for next two months.
And I hope that answers your questions
before I pass it over to Laure.
- Yeah, so the first portfolio
of picture I show you,
so they were publishing Mediapart,
but we also published long investigative
feature on Mediapart.
And Mediapart is the leading
investigative media in France.
So it's influence, but some of
it was translated in English.
So that was our main
collaboration for media.
And then for the research part,
our research was financed
by the United States
Institute of Peace,
which are the big user,
which are the big presence
in Myanmar for the coup.
So the gave us the budget to
do what they couldn't anymore,
'cause this stuff couldn't work anymore.
So it was financed by USAID
and supported also by Article 30,
which is a think tank about
business and human rights
was funded by Matthew Mullen
was a long term teacher
in a Bangkok University.
And he is now back in the US.
And then we have collaboration
with research centers
or journalistic centers
in Bangkok for the moment.
So we have free for two exhibition now.
So our photo exhibition
was shown at the foreign
correspondence club in Thailand
at SCA junction, which
is this research center
of Southeast Asia.
And then we have one at
the moment in the Hague,
in the City Hall, in the
Netherlands, in the Hague
because we want to reach other countries.
So this, our collaboration
and we also at the moment
have a partnership with,
in term of photo, especially.
So SOPA Image, it's a big photo agency
that has been created recently in Asia.
So we will open an account
and they have access to Getty Image now.
So our best selection of
picture would be our label
on SOPA Image.
So we are also trying to teach
about integrating a news photo agency,
how to select a picture,
how to, so we work for SOPA
Image and then Saka Photo,
which is a collective also
who helps photo journalist
in Myanmar since the coup.
We collaborate they help us
getting access to safety training
that we then give to our team.
So everything about cyber security,
safety training, mentorship.
So we work with established
photo collective
to get the advice and to help each other.
Yeah, but for sure if
the picture on the team
managed that would be much easier now
to disseminate in the national media.
And we have...
We work also with short stories
that they want to say a word about,
'cause it's a colleague who was helping us
from the very beginning from this project.
And he founded this
media two years ago now,
and two years ago about human
rights defender in Thailand.
So every feature stories,
every people who fight for gender rights,
for environmental rights,
for political rights.
We love the story feature on this media.
There is no advertisement,
it's good quality picture and feature.
And basically what it does for Thailand,
we try to do with Myanmar and the IDs
to have original feature
investigative media at the end.
So we start with Thailand
and Myanmar and yeah.
That's the ID, yeah.
- Thank you Laure.
- I also want to add in that,
is we really, for our
interaction with colleagues
and teammates, we really,
because we are also very young
and we are also only undergraduates
and we just first start with
doing this kind of work.
We really look up to our collaborations
and as well as interaction
with more established
organizations like Visual Rebellion
and as well as like other,
as our peers from Gail
to learn more about how
to do better interviews
to surface and highlight
more dynamic perspectives
of the coup of the people's life.
And we really have big ambitions
to like produce good contents,
especially providing
insights into what this,
what lives is like in Post-Coup Myanmar.
- Anyway, we actually
wanted to add a page,
we are discussing this week
other page on our website
to promote the work of other groups,
because I think it's really important
to have some solidarity,
nobody's doing this for profit
and it's like helping each other
to get our known work and to collaborate.
For example, we do this
for photo exhibition.
Also we collaborate with a
Burma Woman Organization,
Women Organization of Myanmar
So they provided half of the picture
from women in the streets
and we provided half of it.
And then we make collaboration
with civil society groups
inside Myanmar too.
And I think it's really important
to show the work of other
people and to promote it, yeah.
And we also try to...
Your colleague was mentioning this
about the Burmese version of
course, it's really important.
So now Miko is with us now.
Now, is the one who is responsible
for the Burmese version.
So now we started is
finally in safety with us,
so it can work and it
provide the Burmese version
for our social media channel.
And it disseminate our post
into Burmese Facebook groups
that I will never have idea about not so.
He knows all this generations
that the geek Facebook group,
which has 3 million and
we never heard of it,
20 million thing and it's like.
So our work was much more shared
since we have Burmese
social media post of course
were shared in the right place.
And we are waiting for our next glance
to be able to translate
our website in Burmese,
the whole website so that's the idea yeah.
To reach also-
- I Just want to interrupt
because we have a question from Matida
who has been active with Penn Myanmar
with one of the founders of Penn Myanmar,
and also as a leader of
Penn International now,
and I think can speak to some
of these kinds of connections.
So Matida, you have a question, go ahead.
- Not much question, I
just want to appreciate,
you know, I really,
really feel so grateful
to the work of these two projects.
And I think on the ground,
the highest violent area
is right now is the Karen
vision and Maguey division.
Hopefully we can raise more awareness
about the burning of the whole villages
and arresting and the killing people there
and then raising funding for them too,
not just for the other area,
because the most violent
areas are these areas.
And then another issue is
I might say for the writers
and the some other people
it's really have no platform
to keep their livelihood.
Indeed, even though they
can make, they can create,
but they can make earning out of it.
And they have so much
problems facing till now.
So this is big, big challenge
for them to keep going on.
So this kind of the platform
will be a little bit helpful for them
if they can be reach out or
if they can reach out to you,
something like that.
So I will try my best to help
more reaching out to them
and reaching back to
you, something like that.
That's what I can and also do,
but it's still very hard for
them to keep their livelihood
under their rear-end
name, something like that.
It's still very much challenging.
You know, even though
we are safe right now,
what they do is they
revoke the citizenship.
So I can also be revoked my citizenship.
And then they also cease
and raided their homes
and yeah, the confiscated their homes
and the publishing houses,
that's kind of the atrocities is going on.
That's why the situation,
this kind of situation.
I do hope to be shared.
And also the arbitrary arrest
is not just limited to the adult,
but also to the
kindergarten kids, you know,
if they cannot arrest the parents,
they simply arrest three years
old kids something like that.
So this kind of very big atrocities
would be published I do hope.
Yeah, thank you so much.
- Thank you Matida
I think that raises a
really important point
about the ways in which
our acts of solidarity
also have to think very strategically
about how we can care
for people on the ground
whose risks are so much
greater than, you know,
even though we may put
some labor into something,
the risks on the ground and
basic questions of livelihood
and how we can come up with technologies
to transfer some of those necessities
at the same time as making
the knowledge available
to the world.
There's multiple issues that
are happening at the same time.
So thank you for raising that Matida.
Lisa Brutman, I think
this will be our question.
And then we when we're
finished with the Q and A,
we can also hang out a little
bit in an informal session,
but this will be our last formal question.
Hi, Lisa, thank you.
- Hi, thank you so much everybody.
Such interesting projects.
Thanks for sharing them.
Part of my question was already answered,
I think, but Laure, is it?
From Visual Rebellion.
I wanted to ask about how you're supported
and I'm assuming that from
our place to the frontline
is supported by your
university in Fulbright.
And that kind of leads
me to the question of,
how you kind of perceive of these projects
kind of in a longer run.
Are you sort of thinking about these
as eventually sort of archival projects?
Are you thinking about them like,
as a sustainable ongoing kind of thing?
I'm just wondering if
there are any ideas about,
for their networking,
especially from our place
to the frontline folks.
I mean, we see the wonderful,
like expansion of the Milk Tea Alliance
among many more regional countries.
And I'm wondering if there's a chance
to maybe do that with your,
if that's something you're thinking about.
So kind of what, where are you
thinking about these projects
as you go forward and
especially for, yeah,
I mean, for both of you.
- So maybe Visual Rebellion can go first
and we can go after.
- So the grant we
received at the beginning,
when on production basis,
now you get some budget to
produce a specific thing.
And now we are trying to,
we applied now to apply for
grant for functioning costs,
to be able to function for a year,
to have some income for our team
and to have some emergency funds,
to have the budget for the English lesson.
So we are aiming for
administrative functioning costs
that we ask in the grants.
Our first year of operation was
like showing what we can do.
And now we would like
to be able to finance
a proper newsroom.
I also wanted to add that
everyone has always been fed
with what they produced for us,
the research for the
research, for the picture,
and I tried to apply the same
with international media.
Applying, so you get what I should get
and you produce something.
But for me, the long term, as I said,
Visual Rebellion is what
you create after a shock.
But my long term idea is to
provide the opportunities
and the skills and the
resources for the team
to be able to stand by themselves
as freelance journalists
to make a career like we do.
And then they, for example,
I'm supporting them to entering university
to pursue the studies, or we
support them to apply for jobs
in international urban is media
we're looking for contributor.
So I would consider that my work is done
when everyone of the
student is relatively safe,
has an income and as a
job and as collaboration
and do the career that
he should have done.
So it's a content project,
but for me, it's also
a pedagogical project
and it's not out of course
I have a lot of affection for them,
they are my student, but
it's not out of charity.
It's like this region needs trained,
young investigative journalist
to move forward politically too
and in a societal level.
And my job is being a journalist in this.
So this is where I can contribute.
And I truly believe that if people
are given the technical
intellectual critical skills
to provide the information
that the people need
we contribute somehow
to a change in society.
And as we know that this information
is such a problem in Myanmar.
I mean, there was a lot of
pointing down at Myanmar.
It's something that we see every country,
but the Myanmar case
has been research a lot
because it was intense and
it was focused on Facebook.
And it was focused on
this very horrible events.
I mean, the war in their community,
and there was all this
thing it's presence.
There was a big problem now.
And how do you move beyond this,
beyond the pointing
down and Burmese people,
because this is not the solution.
And it's like, how do
you, what's the problem?
What's the root problem
of this information
and nationalism and all of this.
And for me it's putting people together
and time regional journalists
talk to each other,
see there is common issues,
how we work together,
because you also, in the school system,
there is also a lot of misconception
about all the neighboring countries.
So, and people are not taught
much about other countries,
the original situation
and the military Alliance
has said Lizais was
something really important
and Hong Kong and Myanmar
so are really important
and needs to be supported.
And our way is to teach
investigative reporting,
to teach how to deal
with international media
with international clients
simply so you can have the
chance to have a career,
like all of us here,
despite the terrible
situation in the country.
So yeah, in short,
we try to get Gwen for annual functioning.
And then as I said, I would
consider then my job is done
when all of them as a
stable situation, yeah.
And can do the work, they should,
but Visual Rebellion will always be open.
It works on a volunteer basis,
for the people who contribute,
they're paid for the people
behind who help on the
websites, it's volunteer.
And it's photo editor,
video editor, journalist,
because we believe that you
need to share your knowledge
at a critical time like this,
because if we know we don't do it now,
there is not a better of time than now
that changed the media
landscape in Myanmar.
And we work with a small group of people,
but it has with cushion
because they work themself
in local media in Myanmar.
So what they learn,
we love the cushion in
the whole community,
local community of journalist.
Yeah, so-
- [Lisa] Thank you.
Can I hear from the frontline
to place it, but yeah,
from the other group, thanks.
- Thank you so much.
So maybe I will talk first
and then Tam if I miss
anything you can follow up.
So about the funding and the
affiliation with Fulbright,
we currently, so for the Zine publication,
until now we haven't had any funding
or we didn't have little like
spend any money on the project
but now you're mentioning
about the funding
as well as how to keep the
project financially alive.
We haven't thought about that.
We just think about like how to surface
and how to bring people's voices
to the international community
and especially the Southeast Asian youth,
the Southeast Asian region.
And as Laure was speaking
about the unpaidness
of the journalists, as well as the people
who work in media in Myanmar.
I also know about the case
of civilian reporters,
also raising funds by themselves
on social media platforms,
namely Instagram to fund
for their own traveling.
For example, if they join
the People's Defense Force,
they need to like have their own step in.
No one is gonna provide them that,
and they rise by themselves.
So maybe we are just a group of students,
but it is just something
that pop out of my head
when I think about it.
So maybe either future, some organizations
can like try to have
a more established way
of helping these civilian reporters,
as well as independent
journalists to get paid
for what they're doing in order to sustain
the flow of news about Myanmar.
And, but there's also, thank you to Eric.
So there's also another
thing that I want to raise
is which I haven't seen anywhere,
where people discuss this
is the gray zone of the revolution.
They are, so we have
always see the revolution
as something very binary between
the military and the people
and between the military and the CDM.
But there are like also soldiers
defectors from the military
trying to join the CDM as
you all may have known.
The military Hunta has
a very separate system
in alongside the civilian
government system in Myanmar.
That's why they sustain
until the present day.
And they are defectors,
soldier defectors calling
for help from Myanmar
who want to defect the military
Hunta, but they have family
and they have other strengths
attached to Tatmadaw
that they haven't been able to.
And they have not received as much helped
from the international
community as the CDM
and the civilians, when it
comes to doing the revolution.
I personally consider
them as like the gray zone
of the revolution.
Yeah, Tam do you wanna follow up?
- So circling back to list of questions
about what our next step would
be like given that we are...
So for this specific project
we, as Phuong as mentioned,
we did not receive any fundings
from any institution whatsoever,
and everything was done based
on our dully interactions
with the students and friends
from Yangon University.
And due to the overwhelming
kind of like urgency
of the Zine publication.
We solely focused on that, very,
that one specific thing to work towards.
And now we just started
thinking about, you know,
like what the next step
for us would look like,
but for the next to memory thing,
we'll try out best to get
into events like these.
So again, thank you, Erik,
and Brad as your team
for creating this opportunity for us
to talk about our project.
So yeah, praise yourself for,
I think, more future updates
about how we are gonna
reimagine the project itself,
but again, for the next two months,
I think, we'll be focusing
on promoting the Zine
to the international community.
- Thank you everyone for
this fantastic conversation.
We're at the end of our time,
I'm gonna stop recording.
But first I wanna record us
giving a round of applause
to the speakers and the group.
Thanks, Laure, Tam, and Phuong Anh.
This is really exciting.